[Musique]
atp 7 en grande lande bordelaise
médecins trop nous sommes dans les
années 70 la france découvre le
mouvement hippie un courant
contestataire apparu quelques années
plus tôt aux états unis
à l'époque des milliers de jeunes
français adhère à la philosophie peace
and love
mais leur look et leurs moeurs
libertaires sont loin de faire
l'unanimité dans les villes françaises
exemple ici pendant les 70 à
aix-en-provence genève comme une femme
vous savez c'est une honte de moi je lis
encore pas parce que se décrasser moi je
les rassure et quand je les rassure et
ferreira saurait à 12,0 mal habillé
salle droguer pour beaucoup l'image des
hippies se résume à ça en 1971 à avignon
à l'occasion du festival
la cohabitation difficile entre les
hippies les avignonnais fait la une des
journaux ça dépareille la ville quoi
pourquoi masques dans la rue il y avait
le festival il y avait des gens très
bien qui venait vous rejetez
professionnel jusqu'à maintenant on va
au festival en bout jean
même son de cloche du côté des
commerçants qui parfois n'hésite pas à
employer la manière forte
comment obliger de
arroser et cela vous est arrivé de les
pointer au plus tard hier soir
d'autres au contraire voient surtout les
hippies comme une belle distraction
alors que pensez-vous de libye monsieur
cheikh très bien
il chante bien gens qui toussent et
tripoli vous trouvez pas trop sale pas
du tout pour défendre leur cause les
hippies investissent alors les plateaux
télé en 1973 dans l'émission les
dossiers de l'écran il qu'on passe à
plusieurs intellectuels dont l'écrivain
rené barjavel les vêtements qui vous
déplaisent parce qu'ils sont mis
n'importe comment ça m'est égal
j'ai envie de couleurs j'ai envie de
choses qui me plaisent à moi j'ai pas
envie de suivre une mode j'ai pas envie
net macramé vous suivez une mode non
merci mais s'il ya une mode qui est
qu'ils sont souvent et bien dans le
monde entier c'est la mode hippie non
c'est non seulement il existe réellement
mêle influences
ça n'est pas une mode nous avons
influencé la mode mais nous ne sommes
pas une mode
l'effervescence lippi en france
s'essoufle rade dès le milieu des années
70 mais pour certains la philosophie et
la mode hippie perdure toujours
aujourd'hui
[Musique]